Este es el final de una telenovela que
ha durado siete meses los soldados
marfileños detenidos en julio por Mali
serán liberados así lo anunció en una
declaración leída en directo por
televisión el ministro mariense de
administración territorial
presidente de la transición jefe de
estado ha concedido el indulto con
remisión total de la pena a los 49
marfileños condenados por la justicia
maliense
46 soldados fueron condenados a finales
de diciembre a 20 años de reclusión
criminal por delitos de atentado y
conspiración contra el gobierno tres
mujeres liberadas A mediados de
septiembre fueron condenadas a muerte
por Rebeldía bamaco acusó a estos
soldados de haber viajado con
identidades falsas con armas y sin
informar a las autoridades Costa de
Marfil rechazó las acusaciones afirmando
que sus soldados estaban en una misión
para la ONU esta gracia se produce una
semana después de la visita oficial
abamaco de una delegación madrileña
la transición
[Música]
es indulto refuerza el impulso creado
tras la firma el 22 de diciembre de 2022
del memorando de entendimiento sobre la
promoción de la paz entre Mali y Costa
de Marfil la comunidad económica de
Estados de África occidental había dado
un ultimátum a la junta maliense para
que liberara a los soldados antes del 1
de enero o se enfrentaría sanciones un
plazo ignorado por bamaco el actual
presidente de la cdao se había mostrado
finalmente conciliador prefiriendo dar
una oportunidad a la mediación togolesa
que ha visitado el país en los últimos
días